the divisions inside america couldn't be
more extreme
[Applause]
and fresh pictures like these of what
happened inside washington's capital
building on january the 6th
keep on surfacing
showing the ugly face of america over
and over again
as the more bransac the senate
[Applause]
the mention of senior republicans will
no doubt be used as evidence of how
their words
impacted events last week
and here as the rioters wandered around
america's seat of power
the apparent acquiescence of the police
will both shock
and terrify good sir do you need medical
attention i'm good thank you
all right i got shot in the face
any chance i could get you guys to leave
the senate wing we will
i've been making sure they ain't
disrespecting the place okay i just want
to let you guys know this is like
the sacredest place i know hey know it
i'm going to take it
the constant referrals to what they
believed were donald trump's wishes
means the risk of further violence
cannot be discounted
it's a threat law enforcement in the
states has to take very seriously
at the same time i know that we have the
capability investigative and
and the tactical capability on scene to
protect these locations
and so i'm optimistic that the threat
will be
neutralized but it has to be taken very
very seriously
the center of the nation's capital is
now heavily militarized
with 25 000 national guard in position
there are more american soldiers here
now than in iraq and syria combined
the new administration is on a mission
to accelerate change as quickly as
possible
promising a raft of fresh executive
orders on joe biden's first
afternoon in office reversing some of
the trump administration's
key policies
but the prospect of change isn't
silencing or even reassuring the
country's militia groups
these in ohio turned out in columbus
despite calls to stay away
to exert their constitutional rights to
bear arms
amid a widespread clampdown on social
media
people want to have a voice and when you
take that away from them on social media
it makes them louder here state capitol
buildings
across the country have been fortified
with travel restrictions to washington
heavily curtailed
there are fears of trouble further
afield we are being divided
and torn apart and we are doing it
ourselves
ohio is solid trump land and his
supporters sense of loss
is strong and there's a keen awareness
the power balance has changed
they're obviously here because they're
racist you have to know what's going on
free media why are you giving them a
flap this is free advertising
why do you care what they think are you
racist ma'am
are you raising this young black girl
that lives in my house
tensions are incredibly high across the
country the challenge will be keeping
a lid on emotions beyond inauguration
day
alex crawford sky news ohio